hello my name is Tina pata chala I am
Indonesia's ambassador to the United
States I would like to ask to respond to
the question what keeps me motivated to
this first is the knowledge that our
generation has amazing tools for change
internet education microcredits digital
technology the dissemination of
knowledge and so on and so on and
because of that I think we are the
generation that are most capable to
deliberate change that must be there has
never been so many changes around the
world past our time the back is not
going but secondly the knowledge that
I'm convinced we live in the best
century and that we can lead the best
generation we are already the most
democratic the most liberating the most
connected the most free the most
emancipated for most egalitarian
generation known that in human tissue
and that we need to realize that and use
it as social and political
so you make the 21st century perhaps the
best and the most progressive session
known to human race so let's work
together to achieve done and let's not
waste the tools and opportunity
the never change for one thing